ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
ไม่สวัสดีกูหญิงก่อนแล้วค่อยเป็นสวัสดี
นักเรียนล่ะคะสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงฟรีหานัก
เรียนสวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้
วันพุธค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
10  20 บาท
หรือนั่น
เดือน
กรกฎาคมปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
ปีคศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะค่ะแต่เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะครู
ป๊าเมื่อวานนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
19 เดือน
เดือน
กรกฎาคม AE พ.ตต
ปีพ.ศ
2565  a คศปีคอ
2022 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะครูป๊า
พรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่ 21 เดือน
เดือน
กรกฎาคม
awos ต.ค.ปีพ.ศ
2565  a คศปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะอ่ะแต่ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
15:00 น
3:00 นกี่นาที
7 นาทีค่ะ
บ่าย 15:00 น 7 นาทีน้องก็เป็นตอนกลางวัน
นะคะก็ไปตอนบ่ายแล้วเนาะก็ถ้าใช่ถ้าครู
ฟ้ากับครูหญิงเนี่ยเป็นเด็ก
ลิ่ง
เด็กสมัยเด็กอ่ะอาจจะเป็นเด็กผู้ชายเด็ก
ผู้หญิงอายุ 6 ขวบน้องจนถึง 18 ขวบ
18ปี
8 เป็นเด็กสมัยยังไปโรงเรียน
เนี่ยไปโรงเรียนนะคะก็ถ้า 15:00 นและก็
เรียนหนังสือเสร็จแล้วโรงเรียนเลิกแล้ว
กลับบ้านได้แล้ว
จบ
ก่อนครูฟ้าเด็กๆครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบ
ไปโรงเรียนไหม
ตอนครูบาเด็กๆนะสู้ฟ้า
ไม่ชอบไม่ชอบไปโรงเรียนค่ะครูหญิง
เหมือนครูหญิงล่ะชอบไปโรงเรียนไหม
ไม่ชอบเหมือนกันไม่มีใครชอบเลยไม่มีใคร
ชอบใช่ไหมคะเออล่ะเวลานักเรียนเป็น
เด็กนักเรียนชอบไปโรงเรียนไหมใช้นี่ก็
คอมเม้นท์ไว้นะคะเลยค่ะใส่หมดเวลานะคะไม่
วัน
เวลาที่เราเป็นเด็กใช่ไหมเราเป็นเด็ก
เนี่ยเราเนี่ยไม่ชอบไปโรงเรียนแต่
ครูฝาล่ะนอกอย่างอื่นนะเวลาครูไปอยู่บ้าน
ใช่ไหมอันเนี่ยนครูป๋านะคะครูฟ้าเนี่ยมี
คุณพ่อแล้วก็คุณแม่น่ารักๆฟ้าเด็กๆอาจจะ
อายุซัก 6 ขวบจนถึง
12 ก็พอจนถึง 12 ขวบเนาะฟ้าเป็นเด็กอ่ะ
เวลาภูฟ้าเด็กๆคุณพ่อคุณแม่ให้ทำอะไรแล้ว
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ชอบคำไม่ชอบเลยมีไหมคะรอบ
เลยหรอ
คุณพ่อคุณแม่เนี่ย
ชอบให้ครูฟ้านะคะอ่ะ
ติดตั้งนะทุกวันและชายสกรีนไหมทำให้แชร์
ใช่ปะ
กำลังวาดนาคุณพ่อคุณแม่ให้กูฟ้าทำอะไรที่
คู่ฟ้าไม่ชอบ
กินข้าวเราหญิง
แต่ตอนนี้ครูค้าชอบกินไม่ใช่เหรอคะ
เปิดบางคู่ความไม่ชอบกินข้าวค่ะรูปภาพ
ป๊ากินข้าว
ฟ้ากินข้าว
[เพลง]
แต่ครูฟ้าไม่ชอบกินข้าวฟาร์มไม่อยากกิน
ข้าวไม่กิน
ว่าทำไมตอนเด็กๆคุณพ่อคุณแม่ให้กินข้าว
แล้วครูฟ้าแบบไม่ชอบไม่ชอบกินข้าวทำไม
ขึ้นมา
คุยตรงหน้าขนาดพูดขนาดนั้นนะฮะเพราะกูฟ้า
ในชอบคะอันนี้เนี้ยหาก่อนอะไรเข้ากิน
อาหารเหมือนเป็นแบบเด็กๆอ่ะเหมือนเป็นขนม
เดี๋ยวแป๊บนึงนะคะมันจะเป็นเหมือน
บลูเบอร์รี่นักเรียนคืออะไรเดี๋ยวมันจะมี
เนี้ยถุงเด็กแล้วหรออาหารเด็กเหรอครูฟ้า
ใช่
มันจะอยู่ใน
กระป๋องอย่างเนี้ยมันก็เหมือนบูเบอร์รี่
บลูเบอร์รี่เลยนะอย่างนึงไม่รู้กูไปชอบ
กินขนมนะคะขนม
เนี่ยแนน
เป็นกระป๋องแบบนี้นะคะว่าชอบไม่เลยนะเออ
เค้าอย่างงั้นน่ะแต่มันจะเป็นของอเมริกา
หรือเปล่าของประเทศอะไรหรือว่ายุโรปไม่
ไม่ชัวร์เลยแต่ว่าในประเทศไทยเนี่ยมีขาย
นะคะอ่ะ
cat5 สบลูเบอร์รี่นะเพราะว่ากูฟ้าเป็นคน
ชอบกินบลูเบอร์รี่มึงหน้าอก
ฟ้าก็เลยแต่ผู้ฟ้าโตแล้วใช่ไหมแบบนี้หรอ
ครูป๊าไหนไม่ใช่หวัง
อะไรอ่ะกูไม่ได้อยู่
กระป๋องไม่น่าจะใช่แบบใช่ไม่ใช่มันจะเป็น
อาหารแบบ
แล้วก็กินช่วงไม่รู้ว่าคืออะไรนะแต่ร้อง
แต่ว่าไม่ต้องเคี้ยว
อื่นไม่ว่าจะเป็นนิ่วนิ่วสำหรับเด็กๆเด็ก
แบบเด็กที่อายุแบบเท่าไหร่อ่ะ 6 เดือน
หรือไหมเด็กอายุ 6 เดือนเด็กอายุจะกิน 1
ขวบ 2 ขวบ 3 ขวบก็โอเค
ของเดือนนั้นก็ยังไม่ได้กินนะคะวิ่งไป
ประมาณ 1 ขวบ 2 ขวบสมัยเด็กๆให้ฟันเขียว
ก็ไม่ได้เอากูฟ้าชอบกินอ่ะดิ๊ก็เลยไม่ชอบ
กินข้าวเวลาคุณพ่อคุณแม่ให้กินข้าวกูเขา
ก็เลยไม่ใช่กินข้าวไม่ชอบเลยไม่ชอบกิน
ข้าวแล้วคุณพ่อคุณแม่ก็บอกฟ้ากินข้าววง
ความไม่อยากกินข้าวนั่นแหละมันก็เลยไม่
ชอบกินข้าวค่ะครูหญิงค่ะ
แล้วครูหญิงหรอ
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยคุณพ่อคุณแม่ให้ทำอะไรแล้ว
ครูหญิงไม่ชอบตอนเด็กๆเนาะตอนเด็กๆใช่ไหม
ครับตอนเด็กๆและคุณพ่อคุณแม่ให้ครูหญิง
ล้างจาน
ชอบร้านจานไม่ใช่เหรอ
ที่บ้านเนี่ยเวลาเรากินข้าวเรามันก็จะมี
จาน
แล้วก็มีข้าวอย่างเงี้ยมีชามสมัยไม่ซ้ำอี
ทขอให้มี 2 ช้อนมีส้อมเนี่ยเรากินเสร็จ
แล้วใช่ไหมคะเราก็จะมีกะละมังแล้วก็เอา
ทางหมดเนี่ยใส่กะละมังแล้วก็ล้าง
นอนเด็กๆอ่ะครูหญิงไม่ชอบร้านจานเพราะว่า
ที่บ้านเนี่ยมีพ่อมีแม่สมัยมีผู้หญิงมี
น้องมีน้องบี 5 คน
จานเนี่ยโหเยอะมากๆมีจารมีจารมีชามีชาม
เนี่ย
ตีหม้อ
มีกระทะ
มี
ตะหลิวมันเยอะผู้หญิงก็เลยเอาออกในชอบ
ล้างจานแล้วก็ผู้หญิงเนี่ยก็ต้องยืน
ล้างจานแล้วนะ
ก็ไม่ได้มันอยู่สูง her
นั่งไม่ได้นะนั่งไม่ได้มาตอนเด็กๆครูหญิง
ก็เลยไม่ชอบร้านจานเลย
แล้วลูกค้า
อันนี้มาเนี่ย
อ้าวคำว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยคิดว่า
มีอะไรอีกที่เด็กๆเนี่ยไม่ชอบทำอาจจะไม่
ใช่ครูฟ้าไม่ใช่ครูหญิงก็ได้แต่มีอะไรอีก
ที่เวลาเด็กๆเวลาเราเป็นเด็กหรือว่า
เพื่อนครูฟ้าเป็นเด็กเรื่องไม่ชอบเด็กไม่
ชอบคำหรือว่าไม่ชอบมากๆจนแบบเกลียดอ่ะกับ
พี่ไม่เอา
ไม่ชอบทำ
ความคิดว่า
คะอันนี้ค่ะคุณหญิงอะไรคะคุณป๊า
แปรงฟันแปรงฟัน
เด็กๆไม่ชอบแปรงฟันเวลาคุณพ่อคุณแม่บอก
เด็กๆไปแปลงฟัน
เด็กๆไม่เป็นฟันไม่เอาเบอร์ครูมาหัดคิด
ว่าทำไมเด็กๆไม่ชอบแปรงฟันน่ะไม่อยากให้
มันไม่สนุกค่ะ
แบบนักเรียนคลิปนะเรายืนแปลงฟันใช่ไหม
เบื่อ
จริงแล้วยาสีฟันจะเป็นรสสตอเบอรี่
บลูเบอรี่ขี้ยาสีฟันนะเนี่ยสตรอเบอร์รี่
บลูเบอร์รี่รสส้มเชอรี่นี่อะไรก็ไม่ชอบ
เลยเด็กๆนะไม่รู้หรอกว่าผู้หญิงอันนึงบอก
เลยว่าคะ
เด็กๆอยู่ก็คิดว่าเด็กๆไม่ชอบแปรงฟันแต่
คุณคิดว่าเด็กๆไม่ชอบเพราะว่า
โอ้ยปิดแต่ว่าสีไม่ที่สุดไหมเนี่ย
แรงศีรษะยาสีฟันนะคะยาสีฟันเนี่ยมันเป็น
มินแล้วมันเขตมึงเลยไม่ชอบ
มียาสีฟันเด็กไงเขาหญิง
เนื้อสิบมันเด็กนะคะว่าเด็กก็เลย
เด็กไม่ชอบแปรงฟันเถอะพวกกูฟ้าก็ไม่ชอบนะ
ตอนนี้ว่าคิดว่ามันไม่สนุกแปรงฟันเนี่ย
ต้อง 3 นาทีใช่ไหม
[เพลง]
มันขึ้นซ้อนกันนะมองไม่รู้เรื่องเลยนั่น
แหละ 3 นาทีก็เลยเบื่อ
อันนี้นั้นชื่อว่าเด็กอะไม่ชอบแปรงฟันได้
ไม่ชอบแรงฝันเค้าก็ว่าจะคุยอะไรนะมีสิ่ง
คิดว่าอะไรผู้หญิงคิดว่าเด็กๆอ่ะไม่ชอบ
เก็บเงิน
ห้าเก็บเงินคุณพ่อคุณแม่เนี่ยจะมีอันนี้
ใช่ไหมคะ
เหมือนหมูอ่ะ
เหมือนมั้ยเนี่ยเต่า
อะไรกันให้ผู้หญิง
อาแล้วก็จะหนูช่องใช่ไหมงูๆๆๆนะคะ
แต่ก็จะมีช่องอันนี้ใช่ไหมคะเดี๋ยวเวลา
คุณพ่อคุณแม่อ้าเวลาเด็กๆเนี่ยไปโรงเรียน
คุณพ่อคุณแม่ให้เงินให้เงินแหละ 20 บาท
แล้วก็บอกว่าให้ 20 บาทเนี่ยกล้องมีเก็บ
ด้วยนะเด็กๆเนี่ยต้องกิน 15 บาทแล้วก็
ต้องเหลือ 5 บาทสมัยก็จะเป็นเหรียญเหรียญ
5 บาทแล้วก็เอาเหรียญ 5 บาทเนี่ยเอามา
หยอดออมสินสมัยเก็บเงิน
เด็กๆต้องเก็บเงินเก็บเงินแต่จะ 5 บาท
หรือว่า
10 บาท
18 บาทหรือว่า 2 บาทก็ได้จะต้องเก็บเงิน
เด็กๆจะแบบไม่ชอบไม่อยากเก็บเงินอยากเอา
เงินเนี่ยไปซื้อขนมซื้อโค้กกินจริงก็เลย
คิดว่าเด็กๆไม่ชอบเก็บเงินน่ะยุ้ยใช่ค่ะ
เพลงแต่ไม่ชอบเก็บเงินใหญ่เก็บเงินการ
เงินถูกต้องค่ะกูมาคิดว่าอันนี้ค่ะผู้
หญิงอะไรคะครูฟ้า
ว่าไม่รู้เรื่องเลยทำไมมันทำไมมันอ่ะ
ที่นอนได้ยากผู้หญิงทำ
ตัวเลขรอนใช่ค่ะเด็กๆไม่อยากนอนเธอใช่
น้อยเด็กอยากดูทีวี
อยากเล่น
เด็กหน้าเด็ก
เด็กไม่อยากนอนไม่ชอบนอน
ครูฟ้าจะมีเด็กอยู่นะรู้จักให้รู้จักเด็ด
มีหลานเป็นลูกของพี่ชายภูฟ้าแล้วเด็กๆ
เนี่ยไม่ชอบนอนไม่อยากนอน
บดีนอน
ขี้แม่บอกให้ไปนอนไม่นอนหรอไม่ยอมนอนไม่
ยอมนอน
11 นะ 11
11:00 นเหรอคะครูฟ้าใช่ฮะ 23:00 นพอดี 5
ทุ่มเนี่ยยังไม่นอนเลยไม่นอนไม่ยอมนอนน่ะ
ก็เลยคิดว่าเด็กๆไม่ชอบนอนค่ะผู้หญิงใช้
คะแล้วก็อีกอย่างหนึ่งอันนี้กูหญิงก็ไม่
รู้ครูฟ้าชอบไหมก็คือเวลาที่อันนี้ใช่ไหม
คุณพ่อคุณแม่แล้วก็อันนี้ครูฟ้านะลูกค้า
เนาะคุณพ่อคุณแม่เนี่ยก็จะมีคุณตาคุณยาย
ใช่ไหมอะนี้กูป๊าแล้วก็มีคุณลุงคุณน้านี่
ก็คุณปู่คุณย่าคุณป้าคุณอา
เป็นอ่าคนนี้คนนี้คนนี้คนนี้แอบคุณปู่คุณ
ตาย่าคุณตาคุณยายคุณป้าคุณลุงคุณอาคุณอา
คุณน้าเนี่ยเป็นญาติดูฟ้า
สัญญากับครูฟ้า
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าเวลาที่เราเป็นเด็กๆแล้ว
คุณพ่อพ่อคุณแม่บอกฟ้าเดี๋ยววันนี้เนี่ย
เดี๋ยวเราจะไปบ้านคุณปู่คุณย่าไปเจอเจอ
คุณป้าคุณอาไปเจอญาติกูหญิงคิดว่าเด็กๆ
อ่ะไม่ชอบไม่อยากไปไม่อยากไปใช่ไหมไปใช่
ไม่อยากไปบ้านคุณยายไม่อยากไปบ้านคุณตา
คุณน้าไม่อยากไปๆๆไม่อยากไปเจอเพราะว่า
คุณปู่คุณย่าคุณตาคุณยายคุณป้าคุณลุงคุณ
อาคุณน้าและก็จะบอกฟ้าทำไมทอมจังเลยฟ้า
ทำไมเรียนไม่เก่งเลยใช่ป่าก็แบบไม่
คุยไม่ชอบเด็กๆไม่อยากไปเจอญาติหรอกใช่
ค่ะ
ไม่เอากูมาไม่อยากไปบ้านญาติเพราะว่าบ้าน
ญาติเนี่ยร้อนดี
ไม่ดีก็ร้อนไม่มีเกมไม่ไม่ชอบไม่ชอบไปไง
นะ
ผู้หญิงก็คิดว่าเด็กๆไม่ชอบไม่อยากทำใช่
ไม่อยากทำไม่ชอบนั่นแหละผู้หญิงก็ไม่ชอบ
ใช่ไหมไม่ชอบค่ะไม่ชอบไม่ชอบฟังญาติพูดก็
ไม่หญิงเรียนไม่เก่งเลยเอเอเนี่ยเรียน
เก่งนะเนี่ยอ่าไม่อยากฟังก็เลยแบบเป็น
เด็กๆเนี่ยก็ไม่ชอบโตแล้วก็ไม่ชอบนะคะไม่
ใช่เด็กอย่างเดียว
[เพลง]
โตแล้วก็ไม่โอเคนั่นแหละสมัยหมดหรือยัง
เวลาหรือยัง
ไม่ได้เนาะนั่ง
ไว้นะคะคุณคิดว่าอีกอย่างหนึ่งที่เด็กๆ
ไม่ชอบ
สำคัญลือฮะใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงอันนี้คือครับอ๋อ
เหรอคะ
บล็อคโคลี่บุคคลิ
แค่แล้วน็อตหน่ะคิดว่าเด็กๆเนี่ยเวลาเป็น
เด็กๆคุณพ่อคุณแม่บอกเด็กๆต้องกินผัดเด็ก
ๆก็แบบว่า
มาจิ้วไม่ชอบต้องพักเกลียดใช่มั้ยมิชอบ
กินผักเลยก็คิดว่ากินผักเนี่ยเป็นอีก
หนึ่งอย่างที่เด็กๆเนี่ยไม่ชอบทำมาหาให้
วิ่งเด็กไม่ชอบกินครับแล้วนักเรียนล่ะ
เวลาที่นักเรียนเนี่ยเป็นเด็กๆคุณพ่อคุณ
แม่ให้ทำอะไรแล้วนักเรียนแบบว่าไม่ชอบทำ
ไม่อยากทำก็
ก็เม้นท์คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะคะเหมือนที่
ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าบอกมาหรือเปล่าของเบนซ์
ได้นะคะแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้เราสองคนไปก่อน Dog
แล้วเดี๋ยวเจอกันใหม่นิโยนะคะก็สวัสดีค่ะ
วันที่